foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
a happy afternoon having a furious
snowball fight on the grounds
then cold wet and gasping for breath
they returned to the fire in the
Gryffindor common room where Harry broke
in his new chess set by losing
spectacularly to Ron
he suspected he wouldn't have lost so
badly if Percy hadn't tried to help him
so much
after a meal of turkey sandwiches
crumpets trifle and Christmas cake
everyone felt too full and sleepy to do
much before bed except sit and watch
Percy Chase Fred and George all over
Gryffindor Tower because they'd stolen
his prefect badge
it had been Harry's best Christmas Day
Ever
[Music]
people of
the internet
welcome ladies and gentlemen
Welcome to our first ever
hopefully the first of many Christmas
celebration streams happy holidays Merry
Christmas to you all
uh I am so pumped for this you guys I am
so pumped for this just listen to that
music man as we as we were leading up
getting me in the just getting me in the
spirit
so I am so glad that you guys are here
tonight uh as we just had to read a
little small excerpt there from from
book one wish I could we read more but
you know we don't want to get into the
whole copyright situation there but guys
this uh I've been looking forward to
this one for a long time mainly because
I've wanted to do something like this
for so long
and to be able to give back to you guys
after this incredible amazing year we've
had it's just awesome you know
and fight I put on the little card like
500 in items some to some of you that
may seem like a lot some people not so
much I don't know but I my hope it's not
even about the number but my hope is
that each year we can keep doing this
and we can make it bigger and bigger man
I I really hope so because uh Christmas
is a holiday a time of year that's
that's always been very very important
to me to my family uh just just
everything that it means and honestly
like seeing the way that you guys just
like I mean I mean expect to go talks
about spreading lumos spreading
positivity spreading love whatever you
want to call it
um this year has been just an incredible
year and
I can't thank you guys enough really I
can't thank you guys enough so uh as we
were getting getting started there in
the little countdown I saw some people
talking about the storms so yeah the U.S
guys
uh in vast majority of the US has gotten
hit by a pretty pretty major something I
never even heard of there was some like
uh
there was a technical name for it can't
even remember what it was
but uh yeah it's been like where I live
it's the coldest I've ever experienced
it in my life when I woke up this
morning it was minus seven that's minus
seven Fahrenheit
which I have I have never experienced
that kind of cold we got a little bit of
snow not a lot of snow but I was this
morning I was kind of worried I was
really hoping that the power would stay
on
so far so good but see down here where I
live we're just not we're not built for
this type of weather not built for this
type of weather at all so oh my goodness
hold up hold up Dustin are you kidding
me right now
guys
I don't I have the alerts going down
there but I don't have the sounds
because it's supposed to be about you
guys tonight it's supposed to be about
you Dustin with a did I read that right
a 100 Super Chat
I heard this was the giveaway stream not
sure I'm doing it right Dustin my man
are you kidding me dude
come on
oh Dustin man that is incredible dude
but I can't thank you so much Dustin
Dustin is a regular here on our live
streams if you guys are new if you if
you don't normally watch the live
streams maybe you're just here for the
giveaway hey it's all good I understand
but we do this thing usually every
Tuesday and Dustin
is almost I I think I see you in the
chat every time Dustin so thank you very
much thank you so much my friend
um but then even before that I mean are
you serious L went with five gifted
memberships so it looks like potterhead
Mando Adam Hester Nikki Clint all just
got gifted memberships and then right
before L when we had mutant Pogo
subscribing to the channel uh and then
volte with a super chat as well hey
buddy how's it going man been trying to
become a member can't find the button
not gonna lie if you're on mobile it's a
little bit harder to find
but it's a it's a join button
and I think
maybe some of you in the uh in the chat
who know about it on mobile I'm gonna
type exclamation point join right there
that might give you some help
but if you're on desktop it's a lot
easier it's like right where the uh
subscribe button is
volte thank you so much volte another
regular here and then also Shacks
renewed their membership Shacks thank
you so much for becoming a member of
House wrecking tour here so guys
when it comes to the giveaway tonight
here's the deal you do not have to be a
paid member you do have to be subscribed
to the channel which is free so if
you're not subscribed I'm gonna give you
about five minutes here before we get
into the giveaways make sure you
subscribe to the channel and then if you
want to unsubscribe after go for it but
to enter you got to be able to type in
the chat so we're gonna pull up here in
a second the nightbot will have a random
word that will uh give out to everybody
and then we'll kind of just work our way
through the list so uh let's see make
sure I didn't miss anybody else man
Megan before we got started tonight
subscribe to the channel
let's see then we had Dustin with the
100 Dustin man just and then there's
Noob Noob what is up my friend what's up
man still at work until 1am just wanted
to pop in remind you all to stay
hydrated
Noob always with the uh with this the
stay hydrated message there
as always thank you new thank you for
the Super Chat happy holidays Merry
Christmas to your family and then Dylan
Dylan with a 50 Super Chat guys
seriously tonight is for you guys it's
for you guys ma'am
um I had so many people reaching out
asking how can we help out you know let
me can we can we donate some guys it's
my turn it's my turn but Dylan just like
um just like Dustin there thank you so
much Dylan Dylan another loyal regular
member of the stream uh also a moderator
here Dylan thank you so much man for all
that you do and then Eagle Eye
renewing their membership and then
Stargazer Tim
are you kidding me star Geezer Tim
gifting 10 tier one memberships
let's see who got Tim's memberships
there who just became a member of House
Dragon tour Eagle Eye got one Elizabeth
Jack Gustav butter beerkley's got one
and a mutant Pogo I just uh mutant Pogo
Just
became a uh subscriber a few minutes ago
Annabelle Godwin Nathan oh man I don't
know how to pronounce this one b-i-q-u-e
music's a little loud on Ravenclaw come
on Ravenclaw calm down a little bit here
calm down just a little bit and then
earn earn we got one of the gifteds as
well Tim thanks so much dude Tim another
member of House wrecking tour uh Tim
Tim's schedule doesn't always allow Tim
to make the live streams but Tim is in
the Discord as well uh and Tim is a
moderator here on the channel as well so
super thankful to have Tim here as part
of our community and right behind Tim
Draco with a 9.99 Super Chat Draco what
is up man
thank you so much so this is how the
giveaway works no no it's it's really
not it's really not I need to start
giving away stuff quickly so you guys
will stop we'll stop giving stuff back
to me
oh my goodness man all right well we
could at least go over here let's go
over I don't want to lose our uh
I don't want to lose this music just yet
let me go to the Twitter here because I
just
pretty sure I tweeted it out earlier and
can just pull up the picture here yeah
so here's here's what we got going on
tonight guys
[Music]
so listen up listen up listen up listen
up
how you win here's how you win and then
how you're gonna redeem it
so first if you're not subscribed make
sure you subscribe to the channel it's
free on YouTube hit that little
rectangular
I think it's actually used to be red I
don't know if it's red anymore but it's
rectangular button says subscribe hit
that so you'll be able to type in the
chat
we're gonna be giving away five 25
Amazon gift cards that's where we're
gonna start off the night I will pull up
a nightbot
which I have over here in another window
let me bring it over here though for a
second
so I'll pull up nightbot we'll go to
this little giveaways right here look
see as you guys are typing and chatting
everybody's gonna start appearing over
here
but once we actually set the
um the keyword then you'll have to type
the keyword to show up over here and
then we'll do we'll roll it and we'll go
just like that
so that's how we'll start then we'll do
um one item uh expect to go has been
gracious enough let me actually pull up
his uh
oh let's see I know he's Teespring
[Music]
that's not what I wanted to go to
specto go
there he is all right let's see if he's
got his Teespring linked yes he does yes
he does
and then let me just click on this one
see if it'll take us to the store here
so you guys can get a look at what he
will have here in the shop
I love this uh
I love this little ancient magic hoodie
right here expect to go Legacy so any
any item here I'll take care of it you
guys any any item from expecto goes
merch that you want I'll take care of it
so that's gonna be that's one thing from
expect to go then I'm gonna be doing
three to say three yeah three
from my own merch shop any single item
in here you guys can pick the great
thing about Teespring is they ship
worldwide so that's why if you're
wondering like about the Amazon gift
cards and the
and the Teespring stuff it's not just to
get more Birch out there it's because
they ship worldwide so all I have to do
I can go in I can order it for you guys
and have it shipped anywhere in the
world basically so you can pick any
single item here that you want out of my
shop as well so we've got like the
little animal icon long sleeves those
have been pretty popular this
unforgivable curses man
I I will never wear that one but it was
a design people wanted we've got it in a
hoodie and also in just a T-shirt and
then the other big one has been
oh where is it the hat that you guys see
me wearing all the time it's this hat
right here this retro hat and then also
the Merlin stuff
Merlin stuff has been pretty popular as
well so we'll give away three of those
you can pick any item you want
then God of War Ragnarok digital copy
it also comes with the
let me see here be careful that I don't
show the code on screen
uh let's see we lost our music so let's
bring back the uh
there we go
all right so the digital contents full
game for PS4 and PS5 PlayStation 4 theme
Avatar Set Dark Horse digital mini art
book official God of War Ragnarok
digital soundtrack Kratos darkdale armor
dark Dell X grip darkdale blades handles
atreus darkdale attire and then you also
get the Kratos risen snow armor and
atreus risen snow armor cosmetic so I've
got codes for that again actually hold
on I think I can show this side yeah
there you go PS4 PS5
going to be giving away one of those and
then the big one we'll work our way up
to the grand prize I'm going to be
giving away three digital copies no I
don't have it early
it will be upon upon launch of the game
but actually with uh if it's Xbox or
steam actually no matter which one you
pick I will go ahead and get your your
prize ASAP because Xbox and steam make
gifting pretty easy on PlayStation Store
we might have to we might have to do it
as like PlayStation credit instead but
but yeah so you could platform of your
choice switch if you guys want switch or
even PS4 if you if some of you want to
wait that is totally fine as well so
let's see we had uh Nathan becoming a
channel member Nathan thank you so much
welcome to house rack and tour Annabelle
a member of how oh wait these were the
ones that uh got gifted we said all
those Elizabeth member of House tracking
tour Alicia with the super chat Merry
Christmas really appreciate this stream
I appreciate you guys Alicia I
appreciate you thank you so much for the
Super Chat and thank you for uh sending
the merry Christmas wishes then right
after that we had dream in plays games
with the 499 super chat Merry Christmas
retro so tuning in from under my covers
right
my boys and I we just like cuddled up on
the couch a few hours ago and watched uh
watched a Christmas movie on Netflix
three blankets we all had blankets
it is just crazy crazy cold right now
for a lot of the U.S
thank you so much for your donation and
then we had Luke 73 TNT with a super
chat Merry Christmas to you retro and
everyone watching Luke thank you so much
thank you very much Luke Merry Christmas
to you and your family as well and then
we got uh several subscribers coming in
there falling Shinobi Ben Eduardo uh
Milan in the house Lucas thank you guys
for subscribing to the channel uh Eagle
Eye gifting a tier one membership to
Sharon congrats Sharon welcome to house
Dragon tour
and then miles with a super chat miles
thank you so much Merry Christmas to you
as well miles appreciate the Super Chat
and then Morgan Johnston renewing their
membership as well guys house rack and
tour
I mean it is just continuing continuing
to grow here
continuing to grow
all right man what do you guys say what
do you guys say we do a giveaway oh oh
the thing I forgot the thing I forgot
okay this is really important
I tweeted about this too so there are
several
these comments right here
I hadn't seen any on my channel in a
long long time but they recently started
popping up again
I will not message you guys on YouTube
and I certainly will not ask you to
message me on Telegram
if you see these comments uh there's a
little report button on YouTube report
them I'm reporting every time I see one
so very very important guys very
important with this giveaway here's how
I'm going to be contacting you
my official email
which is
let me type it on screen here so
everybody can see
it's just going to be retro racontour
gmail.com I could type it up here but
that's pretty small
let's go like Microsoft Word here
let's go like Microsoft Word okay
do not
if anyone contacts you or attempts
to contact you claiming they are me if
it is not from this email right here
it is not me
this email right here guys retro
racontour gmail.com anything else
it's not me YouTube do not trust any any
messages on YouTube Unfortunately they
do not have like a direct message system
anymore on YouTube they have one on
twitch but it's a little bit different
on YouTube so we're gonna have to get
creative with how we you might be asking
okay once you pick the winners how do we
get our information to you without
everybody in the chat seeing
so our buddy Nico Channel mod
Nico and I figured this one out actually
most the credit goes to Nico I can't lie
I can't lie so the um the way that we're
gonna do it actually I can go ahead and
set this up right now so you know how we
we do a q a sometimes and there's like a
little box that appears at the top and
you guys can type questions in
when we do that I'm the only one who
gets to see those questions
so no one else will see it so instead of
doing questions I'm going to say when an
item
please type your email here
now if you guys spam it it's just going
to make it harder for me to go through
so please don't click on it and send a
message in there unless you happen to
win because I will be able to it does
show your name with it so I'll be able
to go back and see who won what so it
would be really awesome if only the
people who win type in there and you
just type your email address and then
I'll follow up with you and get the
other details so like if you get one of
the shirts then I'm going to need like a
physical address if you get one of the
digital items then it will be just um
it'll be just an email for that like the
Amazon stuff so I will contact you
um probably immediately after the stream
tonight
immediately after the stream well give
me give me like an hour or so you know
um and then you know just as soon as you
get back to me that'll be how how soon
you can get your stuff but I mean I hope
I hope to have all of that sent out to
you guys before you know before
Christmas and everything but again if
you're just dropping in reminder this is
not being done through YouTube comments
guys so if you see a comment like this
one it's not me ignore it on the naughty
list indeed
very much on the naughty list guys
all right let's see we had another uh
feathers with the Super Chat feathers
thank you so much Merry Christmas happy
Hanukkah happy New Year whatever you
lovely people are celebrating gotta be
with the family catch you on replay
feathers hey thank you so much feathers
for the Super Chat same to you same to
you my friend
and then uh Seth Lilly just subscribe to
the channel as well thank you guys
welcome welcome
well see Eduardo even if it didn't
whenever whenever we have whenever I
start this q a on YouTube I'll be able
to see who's sending it so
so the the winners will be your YouTube
name and then what you type in there
it'll show your YouTube name and then
whatever you type and I'll be the only
one who will see that so
all right so real quick before we get
started any any big questions any big
questions I'm gonna look I'm gonna watch
chat here for a minute and see
if we have any big questions
[Music]
hey thank you Seth thank you
uh how could he become a member Jesse
look for the a join button so you have
to be subscribed first and then after
you subscribe it should appear directly
beside that button it may be in a
slightly different place on mobile
but yeah it's just uh if you go to the
actually I remember how to do it on
mobile
I remember how to do it
if you're watching like one of my videos
you have to click on my name and go to
like the main Channel page if you're on
desktop it's really easy you just look
below any video and you look for the
join button
all right I'm scrolling through looking
at uh looking at questions here can you
win more than once good question Clinton
no you can only win one time can only
win one time
mods are eligible as well I know a lot
of the bigger streamers the mods aren't
eligible but
my mods should absolutely be eligible to
win as well if they enter
oh yeah miles had the same question yeah
yeah that's a good question guys that's
a good question
work computer you're on mobile now nice
looks like Annabelle ah Annabelle
thinking star Geezer Tim for the gifted
nice
all good all good
uh fantasy thinker no tonight's gonna be
a quicker stream we're just gonna do the
giveaway just gonna do the giveaway
listen to some uh holiday music here and
then that'll be it but we will be back
Tuesday breaking everything down I know
like the fact that you guys are even
here on on the Friday Night Before
Christmas Eve you know I know a lot of
people are probably on their way to
family or at family gatherings right now
so we're not gonna We're not gonna do a
crazy crazy long stream tonight
[Music]
uh Jay yes so all you have to do here in
a second
we haven't started it yet this giveaway
hasn't started yet guys but here in a
second I'm gonna go right here and I'm
gonna type a keyword so this is not the
key word but like when James did his he
did of course Merlin was one of his
keywords
so we'll come up with a keyword and then
you guys just have to type that and
you'll be entered your name will be over
here on the left and actually I need to
click that so mods can be eligible too
and that's it that's it we'll do a
different one for uh for each category
so like for
so when we do the Amazon gift cards
there'll be one word for that and then
we'll go to the merch there'll be a word
for that and then we'll do a separate
word for the Hogwarts stuff yeah yeah
explain again it please if you win okay
so if you win actually I hadn't even put
it up so I'm gonna hit it right now
all right so here in a second at the top
of your little chat window you should
see something that says win an item
please type your email here
and so you can just click on that type
your email in there and then I'm the
only one who will Who will see that
that's it
[Music]
so I shouldn't see any names in there
yet and I don't you guys are doing so
far so good
so far so good
but now unfortunately what it did do is
I lost my
I lost my regular chat
there we go we'll have to go over here
we can see the chat here
foreign
have a good one
[Music]
the text is too small can you all the
way oh yeah yeah we'll say it yeah I
don't yeah I don't expect you guys to
read this right here
yeah yeah I'm gonna say it out loud
uh trade out for a different prize uh
unfortunately no no because that then we
would have a lot of uh
I mean like if you don't want to win
something then just don't enter so like
we will um
why does this not repeat I had it on
repeat Loop come on Loop the playlist
so like as we go through each category
so like we'll start with the Amazon so
if you don't want an Amazon card then
don't put your name in
then once if you're like like if you're
only in it for the Hogwarts stuff then
you could just wait and enter for that
one
or like if you really want God of War
you can wait and enter that one
or you can enter all of them but yeah
you can only win one time only win one
time
[Music]
all right let me see here let me go back
to
[Music]
uh no winter ASMR yet I hope so
[Music]
uh no Professor Baxter so we'll as we go
through each one
it'll be clear of what's going to uh
what we're giving away
no Eagle Eye I have not beat it I have
not beaten it yet
[Music]
no Annabelle that's a great question
yeah so that's why we are giving away
like like Teespring will ship to
anywhere in the world so like my if you
win my merch or expect a ghost merch
they make it really easy to ship ship
anywhere
um same thing for the Amazon cards same
thing for the digital items
so I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure
everything we have here yeah I'm pretty
sure it should be worldwide the only
thing
well I'll talk about that when we get to
God of War let's get it rolling man
let's get it rolling all right we're
gonna start off with five Amazon gift
cards guys five Amazon gift cards all
right so here is gonna be the keyword
the key word to win
is going to be Galleon with a capital G
with a capital G galleon
[Music]
all right so actually I might need to
let me refresh this page here
all right so we're going to say keyword
and we're going to say galleon
there you go you guys are getting it
you guys are getting it
gallian all caps that's what we want
[Music]
oh man this is fun dude just like seeing
it pop up over and over
we already have 87 95 eligible users 96
101.
105
[Music]
all these names right here
115 eligible users type Galleon in the
chat guys not all caps just just the
first letter caps just the first letter
caps capital G and then everything else
lowercase capital G and then
a-l-l-e-o-n galleon g-a-l-l
-e-o-n capital G the beginning
[Music]
126
remember we're giving away five of these
that's not bad odds
five out of 127 not bad
not bad
all right we're gonna start rolling them
I'll give you guys another minute
another minute and then we're gonna
start rolling
[Music]
if you're just joining in if you're
dropping in a little late you have just
enough time to get entered type the word
Galleon into the chat capital G
thank you
lowercase a l l e o n
you do have to be subscribed to win
[Music]
but you do not have to be um
you don't have to be a channel member
for this one
all right we're at 141 eligible users
all right it'll keep going so if you if
you drop in and feel free to spam it
like if you're not sure did it count me
or not I'm gonna scroll through here
slowly
you guys can look for your name over
here on the left
[Music]
this first giveaway is for a 25 dollar
convert the currency wherever you may be
in the world a 25 Amazon gift card
25 Amazon gift card guys
all right we're at 144 eligible here we
go we're gonna roll the first one in
three two one boom are you kidding me
noob
let's go
you saw it you guys saw it happen live
it is not rigged nightbot in the chat
Noob winning our first giveaway
oh man
happy holidays Noob congratulations Noob
has given so much to this channel guys
Noob is a regular here
that is great dude that is great all
right Noob so here's what you need to do
now you need to look at the top of the
chat and you need to look for where it
says win an item please type your email
here type your email in there and then
later you'll get an email from uh retro
oh huh I just finished work
moves us oh man congrats Noob I just
need your email noob if you send it to
the uh
if you look at that little thing at the
top you'll find it there
and I know Noob I can get a hold of noob
pretty Noob is in the Discord as well so
all right here we go another Amazon gift
card coming up
boom fuzzy fu z z i e
fuzzy congratulations
thank you
all right here's what I'm going to do
I'm going to start copying and pasting
the names into a document here even
though I could always go back you know
all right so new won the first and then
the second one is fuzzy right there
congratulations fuzzy
so all you need to do now fuzzy is look
for the little uh bar at the top that
says when an item please type your email
here click on that enter your email I
will be the only one who sees that guys
if you're under 18 make sure you get a
parent's permission
thank you thank you fuzzy thank you for
being here and thank you for entering
all right we're gonna roll it again here
this is number three Jesse
Jesse has been subscribed since August
of 2022. Jesse congratulations
gonna copy your name here
all right so we got Noob we got fuzzy we
got Jesse
all winners of a 25 Amazon gift card
congratulations Merry Christmas
I hope you guys aren't I don't see
anybody that's typed their email in yet
so hope you guys aren't having trouble
with it do not type your email in the
main chat that's not where you want to
type it guys you want to look for the Q
a thing at the top of the YouTube chat
q a and it'll say win an item please
type your email here oh you guys love
the yeah that's the desktop wallpaper I
had to I had to include that
had to as soon as that came out I had to
make that my wallpaper so here are three
winners so far I need the email from all
three of you here so all you have to do
is uh look for that little uh q a
click that and then type your email
there
all right here's number four
dark lord Aeron congratulations dark
lord Aeron I remember you from the last
couple streams here congratulations my
friend merry Christmas
foreign
just need an email from you guys so I
can contact you with your with your
Amazon gift card all right and then the
last one
the last one coming up this is for an
Amazon gift card we had a hundred we got
142 who are still eligible even after
these
all right here we go I'm Gonna Roll it
in three two one
in in sautish z i and wait did you did
you win one and expect a ghost chat too
I feel like I remember the same name
foreign
I love how nightbot will show me
anything they type too
congratulations Merry Christmas my
friend
type type in the chat if you also want
an expect to go stream the other day
you did oh my gosh I thought so because
he had trouble with the name too
oh that is so funny congratulations dude
back to back wins
that is great man
all right let's see here all right so
these are our Amazon cards here
right there
all right so I don't have emails from
any of you guys yet these five people
right here I'll call them out again Noob
fuzzy Jesse dark lord Aeron and in
Satish Z
I need you to look for the Q a block at
the top it should be like a I think it's
like a rectangle
click on that and then it should say win
an item please type your email here I'll
be the only one who can see that but I I
need the emails guys I need your email
so I can so I can get your prize to you
[Music]
I'm not gonna I I'm not gonna move on
until I see one of them pop up I'm
seeing people submit questions but I'm
not seeing any uh
[Music]
let me go back here and see if uh so
much luck for one Christmas thank you
hey you're welcome dude happy holidays
[Music]
let me drink mine
yep congratulations we're not done we're
not done guys so the uh the Amazon gift
cards are done but now we're getting
ready to move into the next phase the
merch items
I should probably separate them out too
all right hold on I'm gonna go back here
[Music]
oh I wonder if YouTube has some kind of
protection that's like keeping you guys
from
oh no I hope not
because uh
in Satish Z right here said just sent
the mail is it right yeah it's not
showing up
I'm getting questions from people but
I'm not getting
[Music]
oh Noob tried to oh my gosh I bet
YouTube has some type of protection that
it's not letting you guys post the email
try it like this try to like separate it
out or no I know what to do just type
out the at
so like if you're Joe gmail.com type Joe
and then a t like capital a t try that
oh yeah yours Were Us
m-h-a-g-l-a-i-a just tried it and it
worked but
yeah I bet it's a safety feature Dr
sherbet I bet you're right
yeah so just type like at like spell out
the at
try that uh in Satish Z
yeah if you guys are just jumping in
you're wanting to win we're gonna have a
new code word we're gonna have a new
code word here shortly
[Music]
yeah I bet it does too
[Music]
still not seeing any pop in
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you tried to retype it
yeah I may just have to have you guys
email me that's what James did for his
did some fancy encryption hope that
works
I know right that's I just don't want
people typing their email just right out
in the chat Annabelle that's what
yeah it's like it's it's not it's not
showing any of them
no I didn't see yours either Jesse I
didn't see it
[Music]
not like even if you type it out
[Music]
like if you type out it's like mine's
retroarackintour gmail.com so retro rack
contour and instead of the at sign try
to just spell out a t
that's a good that's a good one dark
lord Aeron
nightbot is blocking it
uh
Nico Nico coming in clutch right there
let me move this to another window
all right let's see spam protection
realtor allows you to time out and white
list links
filter allows you to time out
all right so I bet it's maybe it's the
one with links
gonna disable it
just gotta remember to re-enable it
later
all right
try it one more time guys those of you
who won so
Noob I already I saw yours pop up on
Discord so fuzzy Jesse dark lord Aeron
in sachish Z try one more time using
that thing to to send your uh
email and if that doesn't work we will
um
we'll just do it the other way
[Music]
like you see I'm getting I'm getting the
questions Jesse thank you for the Super
Chat as well and Noob thank you for the
Super Chat to say I love how the the
winners are sending super chats oh my
goodness I could send you on send you on
Discord Noob says
[Music]
still nothing
darn it
just we thought we'd figured it out Nico
just when we thought we'd figured it out
Knight bought on the naughty list
come on nightbot
well hey honestly like you just sent it
is it still broke yeah it's not working
all right I'm just gonna go ahead and
end the Q a
it really was it was a great plan Jenny
I thought it was such a good plan all
right so here's what we're gonna do
instead so you're gonna need to like um
you know how when you're logged into
YouTube you can like hit this right here
and I can see your name I just need to
confirm that I confirm that it's you so
and then you guys can just email me
instead we'll do that that's what James
did with his Okay so
[Music]
winners
send
an email
too
I'm gonna make this larger too don't
worry
[Music]
all right
let's go 35
I want to get that last M on the line
there we go
all right we should probably put that at
the top
the good thing about this is I always
have the VOD so we can
I will make sure you guys get your get
your prizes
ten points from Nico oh man
[Music]
10 points from Nico
nah we can't do that to him
we can't do that to him
how the tables have turned oh dude hey
speaking of nightmare though I better go
back right now and turn that
turn those protections back on
just in case
spam protection okay let's enable that
one again
and enable that one there really should
be a better way to like do you know do
giveaways you know
all right let's do some more giveaways
mod Wars
oh geez all right so change of plans
here's these are the winners of our 25
Amazon cards we got new we got fuzzy we
got Jesse we got dark lord Aeron and in
sautish Z you guys are just gonna need
to send an email to me right here
retroarackintour gmail.com make sure you
spell it correctly
and then
um Noob I already got yours I saw it pop
up on Discord so you're you're good
you're good noob
[Music]
yeah Kitty you're free to leave you're
free to go whenever
like just for that I might I think I
might wait another five minutes now
before we get to the next one so you
you're free to go thanks for stopping by
oh man
should subject line read winner
um no just like screenshot your uh
just so I can make sure that it's you
like if you see how when you go on
YouTube you can hit this right here
and then you can uh like screenshot that
just so I know it's you
[Music]
nah Kitty I I saw another comment from
you earlier so
I saw another comment
if you weren't then I apologize but
come on now come on try
we gotta make sure the winners get what
they win or there's no point in doing
any of this
there's no point in doing any of it
right
[Music]
all right I think we're ready I think
we're ready to move on
I'm gonna buy some Lottery tomorrow
that's crazy in sautish Z1 from uh he
won from us tonight and expecto go
that's crazy
foreign
here we go let's give away what do we
want to do next speaking of speaking of
our boy expecto go if you would like to
win any merch item from expect to go and
thanks to him for helping us out and
joining up to do this uh any item from
his shop here is what we're gonna give
away right now all right so let's go
back to our nightbot
let's get off the spam screen
[Music]
and you know for our buddy
you know for our buddy James we gotta
pick a very special keyword so the key
word is gonna be Merlin with the m
capital
[Music]
if you would like to win an expecto go
merch item type Merlin in the chat right
now capital M
lowercase e r l i n
[Music]
capital m e r l i n
there we go all right
my dog wants out
[Music]
she started whining normally she wants
in
[Music]
dude this like it is so cold outside but
my this hat is super warm actually
I'm almost always cold this hat is so
warm right now
all right we got 96 eligible users type
Merlin in the chat right now guys if you
would like to win an expecto go merch
item any item in the shop
all right one more minute one more
minute and we're gonna roll it
let's get to 100 let's get to 100 it's
at 99. there we go boom hundred
[Music]
all right here we go
three two one
Aiden tries gaming
Aiden tries gaming congratulations my
friend
all right so here's what we're gonna do
expecto go merch Aiden tries gaming
all right Aiden so just send an email to
this email right here retro record
gmail.com uh let me know which one you
want screenshot your name on YouTube so
I'll know it's you
[Music]
and you I'll get in touch with James and
he'll get your item out to you yeah you
probably want to let me know what item
you want too
Merry Christmas my friend Happy Holidays
so yeah just uh let me know which item
and like if it's a size let me know the
size and then so for the for the merch
items guys we will need like a physical
address so like I always stress like if
you're under 18 check with a parent
Guardian uh it doesn't have to be your
name like you could ship it to your work
or something but and I'm the so James
James and I are the only one who will
see that one and then I'm the only one
who will see who will see these so let's
go ahead and jump into some retro
wrecking tour merch now and we're gonna
do a different different command for
this one dang Aidan tries gaming says
congrats dude congrats
[Music]
all right so let's go ahead and close
this out so there's his store let's go
ahead and close this out all right so
now we're gonna do three items from my
shop you can pick anything you want any
single item from our shop here
and we're gonna have a new word for this
one
okay so I'm just going to go ahead and
uh hold on I need to think of my word
before I hit refresh let's see
let's see
[Music]
all right I got it I got it we're gonna
go keyword make sure mods are on there
and we're gonna say all cat actually no
yeah all caps retro
all caps retro let's do it
we're gonna do three of these guys this
is for the Retro reckon tour merch all
caps retro and you should start seeing
your names pop up over here
everybody everybody who types the
keyword is eligible for this one
you do have to be
um
subscribe to the stream guys so if
you're just dropping in and you're
trying to type and it's not letting you
type
you have to be subscribed
[Music]
man I could get used to this music it's
so it's just like puts you in the
holiday mood you know
foreign
let's see
[Music]
I cannot believe how warm I am man
at 122 eligible users right now guys
we'll give it another 30 seconds or so
by the way looks like we had a couple
more
a couple more
um
Jesse with us with another Super Chat
Jesse stop donating It's Gonna Cancel
out your Amazon card
thanks again for the Amazon card emailed
thanks for all the Hogwarts Legacy
content Jesse thank you so much thank
you for the Super Chat and thank you for
all of the support then we also had the
brandonator renewing their membership
thank you brandonator for being a member
of House wreck and tour here and then
pool Cube
pool subscribing to the channel welcome
all right I think it's been about 30
seconds we're gonna give away three of
these
three of these back to back to back up
first we got
elwin
congratulations Elwyn
I know Elwyn said she doesn't normally
wear like
items that have any like branded thing
on it so I don't know maybe we could
elwin could go with like a a mug or
Ellen could re-gift it or something
congrats elwin or Elwyn might just have
to like make an exception you know for
the Retro wrecking tour L one is is a
moderator as well congratulations Ellen
so at least we know it works for uh it
works for moderators as long as I make
sure to check that
all right let me highlight your name
go back into our document here okay so
now we are at retro merch
I cannot believe Elwyn and noob
two of our I mean two elwin and Noob
these two right here regulars like every
stream
every stream
all right I'ma get a hoodie let's go
nice Owen all right next one I'm Gonna
Roll It Dr Sherman let's go another
regular congratulations Dr sherbet
we had such a fun conversation with Dr
sherbet on their first stream their
first time being here about how you
pronounce that word
happy holidays my friend congratulations
all right and then the last retroactive
tour merch item whoa says Dr sherbet
nice nice
[Music]
all right here we go last one
Mary Studios Mary
nice
merry Christmas and happy holidays to
our friend Mary
another regular here as well there we go
nice Mary congratulations
[Music]
all right guys there we go we're over
halfway through
over halfway through
Carlos with a super chat got my
Gryffindor long sleeve shirt hey nice
Carlos thank you man thank you glad you
enjoyed it and thank you for the Super
Chat my friend
good to see you here hope you're hope
you're staying warm whatever part of the
country you were or whatever part of the
world you are in
if you're in the U.S right now it is a
really really cold for a majority of it
all right so here's where we're at guys
here's where we're at three of the top
items are done we've Amazon gift cards
are done the merch is done
expecto goes merch is done now we're
getting into the games we're getting
into the game so we're gonna do digital
copy gotta where Ragnarok all right now
here's here's the important thing on
this one
I do not know much about region locking
I know that I purchased this in the US
[Music]
it does not say anything on the back I'm
just double checking it one more time
it doesn't say anything on the back
that it can only be used in the US
however keep that in mind if you enter
this one we're going to do a new code
but it is a code for the PS4 or the PS5
version of God of War Ragnarok also
includes some extra digital content as
well with that one so that's going to be
the next one alright so let's come up
with a new keyword
[Music]
um all right I got it I got it so we're
gonna cancel this giveaway
refresh the page here and we're gonna go
with
Kratos capital K
-r-a-t-o-s is the new keyword guys
what we should have done boy it's
k-r-a-t-o-s capital K in the front there
capital K lowercase r a t o s
I am the god of war
oh my goodness Stargazer Tim with
another tin gifted
another 10 gifted while we were doing
that last giveaway
guys if you want to be eligible to win
God of War for the PS4 PS5 a digital
copy and it's Gotta or Ragnarok by the
way I don't know if I said that
not the original it's Gotta Wear
Ragnarok type Kratos with a capital K in
the chat right now this will be a
digital code again I got it in the U.S
hopefully it'll be good anywhere I don't
know how all the region locking stuff
stuff works uh but Stargazer Tim thank
you so much Tim looks like Jennifer
thandranen Anna Jesse Stephy with a
gifted membership from Tim Susie uh
ilham Randy and Sirius all with
memberships right there courtesy of star
Geezer Tim you guys get access to all
the emotes in the chat and then we just
uh had two new subscribers Jennifer and
count Grizzly welcome welcome
Carlos with another Super Chat you're
from the USA live in Oklahoma visiting
family in Arizona oh hopefully it's not
hopefully it's not too uh cold out there
[Music]
Dustin with another Super Chat Dustin
says whoever wins this Kratos giveaway
has to give a seven minute loss speech
oh my goodness we got 96 in here right
now we'll give it another 30 seconds if
you guys want to win a digital copy of
God War Ragnarok for the PS4 or PS5
type Kratos in the chat right now with a
capital K then you will be entered I'm
gonna scroll through the names over here
on the left guys
mods are eligible
[Music]
now see I wonder if like if I clicked
off mods or if I click off regulars if I
click off Channel
now it still says 98 or
118 hours
because for the last giveaway I think
for the last two
we'll see we'll see when we get there
we'll see when we get there but I wanna
I wanna reward some of the members too
all right here we go it's only one for
this one sorry guys so the very first
name that we roll here the very first
name that we roll is gonna be the winner
of the God of War Ragnarok code for the
PS4 PS5
boom
are you kidding me
fan Jordan one who just got a gifted
membership from Stargazer Tim also
winning a copy of God of War Ragnarok
congratulations my friend merry
Christmas to you
I hope you enjoy the game
all right so we're gonna type you right
here
[Music]
Gotta Wear Ragnarok
there you go
again here's my email at the top guys
and then I'm gonna go ahead and make a
thing down here for Hogwarts Legacy
digital Deluxe
[Music]
bold underline it
that's amazing nice dude hope you enjoy
the game I have not beaten it yet I saw
somebody asking earlier
not beating it but I just played it a
little bit a little bit more last night
it's great
all right sorry to all of you who
entered and did not manage to win
all right so I'm gonna go ahead and
cancel this one out
and then we're almost here we're almost
here to the end
[Music]
so see Kitty it didn't take that long
it didn't take that long
[Music]
I do apologize if if you if you weren't
being rude I apologize
there was a comment from you earlier
that said something like this is a
cluster and I saw it and it made me get
even more I didn't comment on it but it
made me get even more
like oh because I was trying to get
through all of the names and it wasn't
working right and you just get
frustrated and then I saw the other one
I was like come on now come on
so see it wasn't that long we've only
been streaming a little over an hour
next work no it's it's all good guys
it's all good
all right so here's what we're gonna do
for the last one
obviously this one is very special to us
and to our Channel because how much
we've been covering the game
um I mean that's this game is what
brought most of you here I have no doubt
and we've given away so far it's been
open to everybody as long as you're a
subscriber which is free you've been
eligible but I I have to reward the
people who've been here for a long time
guys and the people who have really been
supporting so here's what I'm gonna do
we're gonna give away one the first copy
and it is for whichever system you
choose does not have to be PS5 even
though that's what's pictured so the
first one is going to be open to all
we're going to do a word anybody can
enter and win that one then the second
one we're gonna do channel members only
for that one
we're gonna do channel members only for
the second one because I I just want to
make sure that the people who have been
such big supporters get get rewarded so
first one everybody's gonna be up for
and then we're gonna do channel members
for these two
foreign
so that'll help if your channel member
that'll help increase your odds a little
bit
and if you've already pre-ordered it
cancel it or you can re-gift you know
whatever you want to do whatever you
want to do so the um
I did see some reports if you guys have
pre-ordered the PS4 version some people
have been sending me messages I know
Draco sent one saying that apparently in
some regions there Sony's just
automatically refunding people
so you might want to be on the lookout
for that if you need to pre-order again
because of the whole change in release
date and and all that so keep an eye out
for that
all right so let's go back to the night
bot here
and hold on let me come up with a word
all right I got it I got it I got it all
right so this one's open to all
and we're gonna make mods eligible and
the word is gonna be ran Rock
with a capital r
an rock with a capital r
guys if you're just joining in you
you've missed a lot of the stream but
you have not missed the Hogwarts Legacy
digital Deluxe giveaway coming up right
now type ran Rock in the chat it is for
your platform of choice
we've had an amazing night so far here
are the winners
here are the winners that we've had so
far we've given away Amazon gift cards
we've given away expecto go merch we've
given away retro merch we've given away
God of War Ragnarok
and by the way guys I'm going to be
trying to follow up with all of you
tonight after the Stream
to uh on the digital stuff hopefully
you'll be able to get that ASAP
and of course on the physical ones it'll
it'll take a little bit for that Elwyn
with another five gifted memberships
Elwyn thank you so much let's see who
just got elwin's uh gift it's right
there the uh looks like Hillary got one
of the gifteds Corey got one of the
gifteds Todd got one of the gifteds
Tokyo Samara got one of the gifteds and
Sassy sis welcome to house wrecking tour
my friends congratulations oh my gosh
everybody look at this we got 209
everybody was waiting to play all their
cards for the for the big giveaway at
the end
they were waiting we got 212 eligible
users right now guys everybody's
eligible for this one everybody's
eligible type ran Rock in the chat with
a capital R in the front just like you
see it here r-a-n-r-o-k
[Music]
r-a-n-r-o-k ran Rock
[Music]
and welcome to the new subscribers as
well we got a uh looks like Jose
Alexander yummy mush gaming subscribing
thank you guys welcome welcome
[Music]
we're up to 230 eligible
it's still going it's still going up
everybody's like yeah we see roll
already would you roll already
I get it if you want to rush me now I
would I I get it
oh my
[Music]
235 eligible all right we're gonna give
it 10 more seconds if you guys are just
getting in Ran Rock in the chat
r-a-n-r-o-k 10 9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1.
Sinjin congratulations happy holidays
you just won a digital Deluxe copy on
the platform of your choice of Hogwarts
Legacy
congratulations I'm gonna put your name
here
I will need you to reach out to me at
this email right here all the winners
actually reach out to me screenshot you
logged into your YouTube account just
just the name just so I can see that
it's you
and we will get you your pro oh if you
win the if you win the digital Deluxe
you gotta let me know your platform of
choice too
so send me an email all you need to tell
me is the platform that you want the
game on
and then we'll figure out the best
option based on the platform we'll get
it over to you
[Music]
man see I feel like it's went by fast
we're almost done guys we got two more
two more
[Music]
all right
I'm trying to think of a good keyword
for the next one
trying to think of a good keyword for
the final one
so this final one guy is going to be for
channel members only so those of you who
just got gifted guess what you're
eligible
you are eligible if you're if you're not
a member and you want to join look for
the join button it's by the Subscribe
button
and blimey
[Music]
let's see here
[Music]
I got one
I got one
all right so we're gonna cancel this one
out right here
and I'm going to refresh and so for this
one we are going to say uh everybody
just channel members
and the key word is
all caps right here
it's gonna be
um
oh no no no hold on hold on hold on hold
on
I don't want it to be something too
complex
oh I got a good one
all caps we're gonna make it Avalanche
all right so this one is just for
channel members only the keyword
Avalanche all caps
that's very fitting right now given how
cold it is for many of us
all right this uh this giveaway here
guys the final two copies Hogwarts
Legacy digital Deluxe for our channel
members
channel members type Avalanche all caps
in the chat right now you get to pick
its platform of your choice guys
platform of your choice
oh my gosh
oh my gosh the comments right now dude
the comments I just see a random bin
snow
just see a random bin snow pop up in
there
[Music]
and while we wait you know what let's
let's watch the Hogwarts Legacy
fireplace for a bit
[Music]
I'm going to mute my regular music let's
get the
let's get the Hogwarts music going
so good dude so good CJ with the Super
Chat lol holy moly the amount of people
I was gonna make a pun about an
avalanche of comments but
I refrained but yeah it just felt like
all the comments pouring in at once guys
channel members this one's for channel
members only Avalanche in the chat all
caps guys we've got 87 eligible oh my
gosh we have that many members are you
kidding me
I mean still though that for the channel
members that improved your odds by quite
a bit we had like over 200 for the first
one
over 200 on that first one
all the comments are snowballing right
[Music]
oh man I hope you guys have uh have
enjoyed this
we'll chat for a little bit here after
we wrap up but I know everybody's got
got family stuff to get to most likely
but if you don't or whether you do man
make sure that you
just like remember what this time of
year is all about guys hold hold dear to
the ones closest to you family friends
um and and honestly like I realize how
blessed I am to have to have close
family and friends and and then like you
guys man like I say that I say that's
with being totally serious like that
that whole aspect of community is
honestly why I got into the whole
YouTube thing in the first place and to
see like see you guys becoming friends
like outside the stream and I see you
chatting and hanging out in our Discord
it means so much dude and and to be able
to make us a place like that because I
know not not everybody's as fortunate
man some people have like terrible home
lives some people really struggle to
make friends in real life but like
online it's it's easier
so to be able to make a place like that
you guys are the best you guys are the
best it's uh it's really awesome so
I'm happy that I can give give back in
some small way all right so we're up to
88 eligible
[Music]
I'm gonna give it uh 20 more seconds if
you're a channel member you could type
Avalanche in the chat right now all caps
a-v-a-l-a-n-c-h-e
all caps in the chat right now to be
eligible
to win a copy of Hogwarts Legacy Deluxe
uh Sinjin
congrats my friend yeah right here right
here
right here Sinjin
all right here we go we're gonna roll it
all right the first one
JP raven fire
that's the name I recognize
oh look JP just typed I just typed it
again too making sure to get in there
you got it in there JP congratulations
my friend Happy Holidays congratulations
I'm gonna go here
into the document
put your name right there
[Music]
and then we're gonna do one more we're
gonna do one more you do not have to
type it in again you guys can if you
want to be sure but
I'm just gonna scroll through scroll
through here
[Music]
scroll through
all right here we go the final one
the final one
as the music as the music builds
zutara babe zero nine
zutura Bobby I know I've asked you how
to pronounce before I know I've asked
you how to pronounce before I've seen
I've seen your names several times in
the chat congratulations
you just won a copy Hogwarts Legacy
digital deluxe edition on the platform
of your choice
and there we go you guys there we go
there we go
here are our winners for the night
[Music]
oh I'm waiting to see if they I always
want to see what their first comments
there it is OMG
oh man I always want to see that first
comment hey you're welcome you're
welcome Merry Christmas happy holidays
I'm glad
that you want to give away alright so
let me go ahead and close out here head
back to the Dashboard please after
tonight I was like I don't think I've
seen Wolfie in here is Wolfie here
no that's gotta be from last the last
stream the top chatter
lowercase Logan and Jesse with a Jesse
with another one last Super Chat I need
to go it's 2 am in the UK hope everyone
has an amazing holiday amazing Community
thanks again retro Jesse thank you for
being here my friend and thank you for
the Super Chat and then right off the
off the heels of Jessie's Super Chat
this is just a little too loud hold on
it's a little too loud
lowercase Logan what is up my friend
Happy Christmas retro and chat thanks
for these awesome streams shout out to
all the peeps in the Discord yes indeed
lowercase Logan thank you thank you so
much
all right guys Here's the final list
Here's the final list so here's what you
need to do you need to send me an email
here
and just for the the sake of you know
maintaining Integrity of the of the
giveaway
if you can screenshot you logged into
your YouTube so I can see your your
YouTube name here because I know not
everybody has the same YouTube as their
uh
[Music]
as their email so
[Music]
all right I'm keeping this up just for a
couple more seconds in case actually let
me read thermal one more time
if you somehow I think most of the
people responded in the chat I think
most everybody knew that they won so
with the Amazon cards we got Noob fuzzy
Jesse dark lord Aeron in Satish z a
expecto go merch Aiden tries gaming the
Retro merch we had Elwyn Dr sherbet Mary
Studios the copy of God of War Ragnarok
thandranen won that then for the
Hogwarts Legacy digital Deluxe we've got
Sinjin JP raven fire and zootera babe
zuturobabe
let's see if they told me oh I already
closed out of that screen I was like
let's see if they told us how to
how to pronounce it correctly
happy Christmas everyone yes Dr sherbet
wait you're confused what hat what do
you mean
wait did we get another oh lowercase
Logan nice nice
do you think this counts as gambling
trading time for a chance to win
email you as soon as the stream is over
watching on my TV oh gotcha dandren all
good all good
I just want to wait and see what uh
what
somebody was Dr sherbet was confused
about something
fuzzy will there be Hogwarts like it's a
game stream after release oh yeah
oh yeah for sure
I hope so Eduardo not yet we haven't
seen one yet
yeah if you guys have the same name on
Discord feel free to hit me up there too
feel free to hit me up there
[Music]
dust Dustin what
what is happening
are you kidding me Dustin with a 50
dollar Super Chat I think I'm starting
to understand the giveaway better now
learning from volte thanks for all you
do retro mods and chat in general
fantastic community of people uh and
lovers of all things Harry Potter Dustin
dude
save your money man save your money
thank you so much Dustin
happy holidays Merry Christmas to you
and your family Dustin means a lot means
a lot Alicia spare some of that money
for me Dustin
uh Evan and toxic just subscribe to the
channel as well Legend indeed right
Dustin is just like oh this was supposed
to be about you guys tonight guys it's
supposed to be all about you
all about you but I know I know chat
always wants to show show some love to
uh toxic subscribe to the channel as
well
Annabelle's so generous with your time
and gifts thank you for this it's been
lovely looking forward to streams in the
future yes yes
thank you
Psalm dust are you look you look adopt
that's funny I don't know how much to
see when it comes out because I have to
wait till April oh you get doing like
the uh either PS4 or
[Music]
um Martin I think we'll be able to swim
but not dive is what I predict
that's what I predict
yeah Morgan I I hope to I hope to be
streaming it yeah
[Music]
Blue Moon surprise gameplay showcase
number three hosted by retro release in
three two nope nope
definitely haven't filmed anything so
and haven't signed any ndas either
so I'm kind of I'm like 100 being 100
honest with you guys all jokes aside I
uh
I'm starting to wonder if they're gonna
do a third one
I feel like it's like so close to launch
at this point you know
I mean it's December 23rd right now I do
feel like I do feel like it would they
would have already recorded
and I 100 haven't recorded anything guys
100 haven't recorded anything
unless unless they recorded like
I don't know man like they recorded
mid-January or something and then
turn it around within a few weeks like
right before launch like right before
ilhan or ilham somehow I still don't
believe this
hey I've told the Stream
you can ask the regulars I would never
straight up lie to you guys I would
never outright lie
would I avoid absolutely of course like
if he had signed an in D.A you'd have to
avoid a lot
you'd have to avoid a lot
but I think the regulars would they know
the regulars know
that when I say I wouldn't lie to you I
wouldn't lie to you guys so
it is what it is man Noob what
I'm gonna have to end the stream I'm
gonna have to end the stream so you guys
will stop this Noob you just want a gift
card my friend and now
so Noob wins Noob wins a 25 gift card
guys
and then turns around and gives a 122
dollar Super Chat
so if you're one if if the mat's a
little fuzzy for you
that's a net going back to me at 100.
Noob it was supposed to be you getting
the gift tonight my friend it was
supposed to be you
oh my goodness Noob Merry Christmas
retro this is my present to you enjoy
your holidays have fun with your family
should probably head off got work in
seven and a half hours remember the Dark
Army is always watching this is your
favorite Noob over and out Noob oh my
goodness what what can we say about Noob
guys Noob is such a
oh such a huge supporter of the Stream
here every stream
always just giving super chats
gifted memberships and now just this
massive massive Super Chat noob
I can't thank you enough my friend thank
you very much like I I feel
it's like what's that oh man it's like
here's your 25 I'm gonna I should change
noobs that's what I should do I should
up noobs gift card to like a hundred
dollars
oh my goodness Noob making sure retro
has enough to stay high hey between the
two of you Dustin and noob
exactly Apollo that
gotcha Noob gotcha
oh oh did I add an extra zero here noob
did I add an extra zero
that's how it works rich or what he
gives comebacks to you I mean well see
that was I was trying to get back to you
guys tonight
oh man
all right guys in all seriousness I hope
you all have had as much fun tonight as
I have
um if you all are traveling be safe stay
warm
um remember what's most important this
time of year guys
your family your friends your faith
your community our community right here
guys it means uh you guys mean so much
to me man and we're just getting started
this year we gave away it was right
around well depending on all the items
people pick and stuff it's gonna be
north of 500 that we're giving away in
total uh next year I'd love to see us
like double it man I'd love to see it be
doubled tripled quadrupled I just want
this giveaway next year like here's how
many we had that won this year
these are the people that won this year
next year I'd like for this list to be
like I don't know like three times this
size
[Music]
I think we can get there man I do I do
it's been a crazy 2022
2023 is gonna be even crazy
yo the James just pop in the chat
I see a bunch of people saying hi to
James
what's up dude
yo happy holiday stream sorry I'm late
all good James it's been a wild one man
it's been a wild one here are all our
winners right here
we got
um let's see who won your merch James
Aiden tries gaming one
don't know if they're a member of your
community as well but they they won and
I kid you not James knew but won our
first gift card of the night Elwyn got a
merch item and then here are the three
that won the Hogwarts Legacy digital
Deluxe
[Music]
but yeah what a stream what a stream
Noob is the chosen one
congrats indeed yeah uh James I just um
if you didn't see your I I emailed you
back James I I gave away a merch item to
James's stream as well
so we got that taken care of and sent
out to the person uh but guys thank you
so much go spend time with your families
with your friends
um
if you want to spend time with this
community exclamation point Discord in
the chat always people hanging out there
we'll be back on Tuesday though uh I
should be I'm I'm off work all next week
I might even do some game streams next
week I know James has been doing some
streams over on Twitch they've been
going pretty well so you might have to
to stream some games but
um congrats to all the winners
um be safe guys have a wonderful holiday
Merry Christmas and I'll see you guys
before the new year so thank you all
again for being here
[Music]
foreign
[Music]